Ouais ouais ouais, ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais! En ce moment ma nouvelle passion c'est de regarder les gens streamer sur twitch parce que j'ai
Bah j'ai aucune vie sociale en fait ! Non franchement je kiffe l'ambiance, les communautés sont cool, euh j'y passe beaucoup de temps c'est p'têtre pour ça que
que je fais très très peu de, de vidéos d'ailleurs
Alors pour ceux qui ne savent pas, twitch c'est un site super connu où les gens ce film en
direct en train de, de jouer aux jeux vidéo ou,ou faire ce qu'ils veulent d'ailleurs ça s'appelle streamer: je stream, tu stream, il stream,
nous streamons. Twitch c'est LE site de streaming
je pense le plus connu
où tu retrouves bah les puristes. Bon y'a aussi youtube gaming, très cool également où tu retrouves on va dire le grand public
et puis d'autres sites moins connus ou tu retrouves
bah personne... alors il ya des méga stars  hein sur twitch pour ne pas le citer
"Ninja" le mec c'est devenu la mascotte de Fortnite il joue avec Drake, Travis Scott
Il a fait le tour des plateaux télés américains, il fait des pointes à 667 milles viewers
Heu... plus ? Plus de réussite encore ? Peut-être éventuellement poser le pied sur Mars ch'ais pas ?
"Ninja viens de poser le pied sur Mars" Oh pu**** !
Excusez moi? Je comprends pas le concept de regarder des gens qui jouent à un jeu, fin je trouve ça ridicule.
Je préfère largement regarder des vrais trucs à la télé comme le golf où là ce sont des gens qui qui qui jouent à
à un jeu...
Moi j'trouve que c'est toujours divertissant de regarder des gens jouer, surtout quand toi même à la base t'es joueur. Bon et puis les streamers
pour capter leurs audiences ils sont souvent très inventifs; taré mais inventifs: entre le mec qui finit les jeux avec des bananes,
le mec qui lit entièrement le dictionnaire, et plein d'autres trucs chelous
ouais, tu t'emmerdes pas
Ah oui... twitch ça fonctionne pas mal sur le don donc si les gens apprécient c'que tu fais ils peuvent te donner de l'argent
du coup c'est vrai que ton niveau de vie est entre autres rythmée par la générosité des viewers quoi.
Bonjour à tous, ça y est je me lance sur twitch ça devient désormais mon métier
"don d'un million d'euros" bon bah j'arrête twitch merci à tous pour cette expérience de six secondes je vais désormais vivre aux Bahamas. Chérie je veux un chien Louis Vuitton !!
Même si chaque streameuse et streamer sont très différents tu remarques quand même parfois quelques récurrence et je vais pas me retenir pour
pour vous les évoquer hein? C'est parti: le pro gamer. Hein comme on dit "pgm"
Putain j'ai mal joué là, ça me saoule. Celui qui débute et qui est déjà à fond:
wooo, yes, bienvenue sur mon live j'espère que vous allez bien vous êtes actuellement en direct au nombre de...
zéro, zézéro à me suivre bon bah du coup ça serre rien que je parle. Bah celui qui vit encore chez sa mère
Titouan à table ! Vas y maman steuplaît encore un peu !
Tu viens manger ou je débranche internet ! Vas-y maman !...
Celui qui veut absolument trouver un nom à sa communauté: Bonjour mes petits chats ça c'est déjà pris, Bonjour mes
motociste ouais nan ça c'est nul, Bonjour mes musaraignes... Ah !
Bonjour mes petites fougères j'espère que vous allez bien. Celui qui veut absolument utiliser tout le potentiel
de son siège de gaming. Yes
merci à Timothée26 pour le sub.
J'ai du mal à voir l'écran, je je contrôle très très peu mon personnages enfaite. Celui ou celle qui veut faire de l'audience sans se prendre
trop la tête: Bonjour mes p'tites fripouilles j'espère que vous allez bien attendez je fais juste un petit changement au niveau de la cam
voilà là c'est beaucoup mieux alors... Le streamer technicien
hein aussi Michel Darty un deux, un deux et quand j'tapote comme ça vous m'entendez ?Allo ?!
je monte un p'tit peu le débit de l'image. C'est bien ?C'est fluide ?
Celui qui partage toute sa vie privée: Donc là, ma femme est en train d'accoucher c'est énorme !
merci pour le sub spamez le mode bébé et demain j'enterre ma grand-mère à 18 heures soyez présent aller pousse chérie pousse, pourquoi il est noir ?
Celui qui est très proche de sa communauté: Alors, ouais, Fred, Fred Molotov c'est pour te dire que le dîner est servi
Bah bon appétit. Merci .
Tu peut y'aller c'est halel. Le streamer ultra sponso: Ba ba ba ba babybel
Bonjour à tous, bienvenue sur mon stream que j'vous le rappelle est sponsorisé par Leroy Merlin.
Aujourd'hui, on va jouer à Battlefield, un jeu qui est disponible à la Fnac, chez Darty et chez Boulanger
Ah, là on vois plus mon visage mais sachez que je suis très très content.
Let's go. Le streamer un peu maladroit: Allez, bye bye mes petites fougères, je vous aimes, je vous kiffes, je vous adores
Ciao
Communauté de me*** ! Pu**** je les détestent tous!
Yes, j'ai pas déconnecter, aller à demain. Le streamer A.S.M.R.
Et voilà, on est très à l'aise dans son petit canapé et peut-être que les bruits de bouches comme ceci viennent
tout doucement vous carresser l'oreille.
Surtout que j'ai manger du pâté à midi peut être que des petits bouts de pâté son coincés dans mes dents
Et oui, il y a le feu chez moi alors je prend tranquillement l'extincteur comme ceci, je le caresse
Allo les pompiers, il y a actuellement le feu je vais totalement mourir.
Celui qui se lance des petits challenge, hein, comme par exemple streamer 48 heures non-stop
(ronflement)
Et pis y'a moi... merci à tous merci d'être si nombreux à me regarder aujourd'hui vous êtes près de 1000
c'est pas mal du tout hein, c'est super "Gotaga vient de démarrer un live"
Ah ! Yes !
Bon bah il reste une personne bah merci à cette personne de...
A bah non c'est moi en fait. Il existe aussi la twitch con, c'est un gros rassemblement
twitch aux U.S.A. durant cet événement il y a  des compétitions de E-sports ;de jeux vidéo. Y'a des gens qui sont capables de faire
le tour de la planète pour y participer: Il s'est entraîné toute l'année
Il a traversé toute la terre pour participer à cette compétition internationale
toute sa famille croit en lui des millions de viewers ont les yeux braqués sur lui maintenant, il va jouer, three, two, one
LET'S GO
Merci à tous d'être venus je rentre directement chez moi
Air France c'est là ouais
Bon voila y'a encore plein de trucs à dire le sujet est, est vaste alors pour info cette vidéo est pas du tout sponsorisé
c'est juste un petit coup de coeur car oui j'ai j'ai un coeur en tout cas comme vous le savez moi je suis 100% youtube
mais j'ai quand même une petite chaîne twitch donc s'il apprécie les top 1 des dizaines de frags de qualité les actions incroyable de pgm
bah n'y allez pas par contre parfois on rigole bien donc venez me suivre c'est twitch.tv/normanstream le lien est
géographiquement présent dans la description. Ciao. Et vous alors, quel est votre streamer préféré dite le dans les   commentaires
Et ouais c'est une fin A.S.M.R.
Titouan ! Maintenant tu sors les poubelles !
Attend, je dis aux gens je te mettre un petit pouce en l'air si vous avez aimé et de vous abonner à ma chaîne
J'te préviens, je débranche inter...
Oh nan !
Abonnez-vous à ma chaîne youtube c'est indispensable pour la survie de la planète
cliquez avec votre doigt ou votre souris sur la putain de grosses têtes de chtis. Merci